Rusia reivindica el control de un
asentamiento al sur de bakmuth en la
provincia de donnietsk el Ministerio de
defensa de Moscú habló de apoyo aéreo
para hacerse con esta localidad Y al
parecer también contaron con ayuda del
grupo Wagner el ejército privado
paramilitar ruso que ahora tiene
expresidiarios en sus filas en el eje de
Nieves unidades de asalto de voluntarios
con apoyo de fuego de la Aviación
operativa táctica y del ejército tropas
de misiles y artillería del distrito
militar Sur liberaron la República
Popular de donieska el grupo Wagner
había dicho este jueves que ya la
controlaba en el pueblo de unos 400
habitantes las unidades de esta milicia
llevan meses enzarzadas en una batalla
de desgaste con las fuerzas ucranianas
la semana pasada las fuerzas rusas
también dijeron haber capturado soledad
Al noreste de bahamut aunque los
ucranianos afirman que aún en lugar está
en disputa allí llegó la ayuda de las
Naciones Unidas
nuestros colegas En Ucrania acaban de
llegar a las zonas controladas por el
gobierno cerca de soledad en doblas
oriental de Don ies con un convoy
humanitario de tres camiones Para apoyar
a más de 800 personas que permanecen en
las comunidades de los alrededores de
Soledad estamos trayendo alimentos agua
kits de higiene y medicamentos y otros
suministros médicos
mientras en kramators el gobernador de
doniets informó que un misil Ruso había
impactado en la ciudad del este de
Ucrania cerca a una guardería la policía
en el lugar aún evalúa el alcance de los
daños